[Music]
here we go the last trailer of Godzilla
Manus one and oh my goodness there is a
lot to unpack here one thing I can say
is I'm deeply jealous of the Japanese
right now not for their high-tech Rises
or work ethics but yeah cuz they are
going to see the movie today and for the
entire month before any us do so anyway
let's make do with the time that has
been given to us like Gandalf always
said let's get to it the trailer opens
in the high seas with a couple of Patrol
boats inspecting the wreckage of a ship
probably destroyed by Godzilla the ship
seems to be a large auxiliary ship and
not a battleship due to the lack of guns
or Weaponry on its Hull it looks to be
deeply mangled and torn not bearing the
markings of any naval battle or
explosion the towers and parts of the
upper Hall are bent down and broken with
signs of claw marks and also blood
splatter I'm guessing this would be
after the formation of the task force
sent to search and study the Aquatic
organism as warned by Douglas MacArthur
in a letter to the Prime Minister of
Japan it is evident that the ship has
been damaged Beyond repair but it isn't
sunk yet it is merely dead in the water
and deep in their minds they know it's
the work of Godzilla but exclaims in
shock as to what did this to a large
vessel then the scene immediately shifts
to one that was seen before of Godzilla
swimming beneath a battleship a for
boing and a telling sign of the one
responsible for the
Carnage then the trailer says this
December meaning this footage is meant
for the entire world at least the
countries where Godzilla minus one is
confirmed to be showed in the US Canada
UK Germany Italy Spain and others and
then we get a scene of one of the
Japanese leaders addressing a newly
formed committee to rebuild the nation
amidst the defeat they suff suffered
after the second world war it goes on to
show the rubble and destruction caused
by World War II after 1945 but then this
shifts to say a new reain and then
Godzilla's foot stomping the ground a
shut that we have seen before this tells
us two things side by side Japan facing
a new challenge in rebuilding their
country and being under Allied
occupation signifying a new Reign by the
Allies after World War II and at the
same time foreshadowing the coming of
Godzilla and his new reign of terror
then immediately we see different shots
and also slightly extended scenes of
Godzilla in Tokyo most specifically
Godzilla comes ashore in the Eastern
Tokyo region the Tokyo bay and then goes
on to destroy a train at the shinagawa
railway station the large station
serving the southern Tokyo region and
Yokohama all I can says that Tokyo is
doing a good job in showcasing the
post-war ERA with the attire and
clothing the correct architecture as
well as everything in team with that
time period all for 15 milli milon $5
million Hollywood take note please in
the background we can see train
compartments and cars being thrown about
as if Godzilla was kicking Legos in a
room imagine the shock and fear these
people are feeling at that time unaware
of any living creature that size and for
unknown reason they have to bear the
wrath of something they have no idea of
like a curse after a curse we then get
to see the actress Mami hamabe acting as
noro Oishi in the movie in a State of
Shock in seeing Godzilla walking towards
the building she is in it's the same
sequence that she exclaimed is that
goira in an earlier trailer showing that
she at least was working for the
government and there is a circulation or
a rumor being spread about about
Godzilla coming Inland but I think the
government was trying to hide this from
the public and somehow understandably so
the Japanese were just getting out of
the war and their morale is zero and if
the ones they elect were to tell them
about something they themselves cannot
stop or explain that would create fear
and panic leading to unrest and
Revolution then okay enough about the
politics the next scenes show bits and
pieces of people interactions tying down
the story to the human elements that we
can all relate to otherwise it'll just
be like kotm good monster fights but bad
quality character development the
trailer touches on many aspects of the
show really immediately after that we
see an extended scene of Godzilla biting
on a train like the iconic 1954 shot and
in the train compartment there was a
woman stuck there trying to hold on for
dear life H she won't probably make it
that train will not be put down gently
on the ground it'll be tossed away and
she would be crushed along with it
tragic this scene really grounds us to
the horrific reality of a Godzilla that
hates humanity and there is no freaking
hope for the ones who are in his path of
Rampage a true horror for the people
unfortunate enough to be there and a
great and terrifying ordeal for any of
the survivors as they said in previous
statements this movie will be a tragedy
a horror and also an action fil piece we
then are shown to the same shots we saw
in the earlier TV spot Godzilla roaring
against a mushroom cloud of his own
making or an atom bomb explosion is yet
to be a certain but this will probably
be connected to the last scenes of this
trailer which we will explain okay
skipping the already seen parts of
Godzilla's carnish in Tokyo we come to
the ocean battle scene where God is
chasing after a patrol boat which can be
tied to the first scenes of the trailer
of them discovering a destroyed Naval
vessel and then probably being chased by
Godzilla he is also confronted by a
group of Destroyers and frigates which
are smaller than battleships but
nevertheless talking about weapons
they're still packing all right so the
patrol boat is being chased and in order
to stop Godzilla from reaching them they
dropped a sea mine which then prbly is
exploded in contact with Godzilla in a
way surprising him and pausing his
Pursuit for a while fast forwarding a
bit uh we see that a patrol boat
carrying Kenji and the crew would be
saved by the intervention of the Navy at
least the Defense Forces of Japan their
remnants of a Navy but sadly this won't
be enough as even with the massive guns
Humanity's weapon Sease to be of any
effect to the Gman this I think will be
connected to the atomic block at Sea
where the ship is destroyed by an atomic
breath that has an atom bomb like
explosion on impact so rewinding a bit
between the Naval scenes we see Godzilla
roaring near the clock tower in Tokyo
probably before reaching the metro line
but also maybe before reaching a capital
or a government building but this is
shown to be in conjunction with battle
tanks of the Japanese Defense Forces
shooting their shots at the king of the
monsters these tanks are remnants of the
Imperial Army they are the type four
Cheeto medium tanks equipped with 75 mm
main guns which are understandably so
slightly enlarged in the movie for
cinematic effects let's say anyway this
won't do much to Godzilla if the naval
ship's guns double their sizes and with
more powerful shells can't do squat what
can they do anyway now after that we
come to the most interesting and most
terrifying part of the trailer the
dorsal
blades so remember the last TV spot
where we thought Godzilla would have an
axe head on his tail the god ax and then
we kind of thought maybe this is
something else entirely
yeah this is something else entirely
Godzilla here will have a new ability or
at least a new novel way to charge up
his nuclear cells in order to fire an
atomic breath here the central dorsel
plates the central ones of Godzilla will
emerge out of his armored skin layer
well at least for the ones in the tail
part they will come out in sequence like
a goddamn horror scene before we get
shocked by the Pug guys so Godzilla here
has these in his body and by Instinct he
knows how to activate them before
unleashing his deadly weapon meaning
that these dorsal plates must be out in
order for him to fire his heat ray the
dorsal plates on the back all of them
will also increase in height pop out a
bit more and then all of his back will
be covered in an atomic blue glow
reminiscent of the same color seen in
GVK but his breath will have an atomic
explosion Godzilla here can take his
time doing this CU he has no other
monsters to fight and also it adds to
the suspense as well as a cinematic
thrill so Godzilla minus one come for us
we can hardly
wait so if you like this video then
check this other one as well and if
you're more interested in other movie
monsters and creatures then check out
our Channel as well we might just have
things you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you on the next
one take care
[Music]
fam